et si les yvelines devenait le pôle
d'innovation de renault avec le plan
d'économies présenté par la direction le
programme prévoit deux milliards
d'économies notamment une réduction de
800 millions d'euros des coûts sur
l'ingénierie
objectif réduire la diversité des
véhicules tout en concentrant le
développement des technologies à haute
valeur ajoutée sur les sites d'île de
france notamment au technocentre de
guyancourt où sur le site de villiers
saint frédéric
ce que nous voulons faire de la france
c'est vraiment le coeur de notre
ingénierie
alors effectivement il peut y avoir
quelques petits mouvements d'effectifs
sur sur la france parce que nous
utilisons mieux notre réseau mondial
mais surtout nous allons concentrer en
france toutes les technologies de pointe
et à forte valeur ajoutée nous ne
refermeront qu'un seul site à l'horizon
2022 sur nos 14 sites industriels en
france s'est choisie pour lequel nous
allons valoriser les compétences en
région parisienne avec le transfert des
activités de choisy-le-roi l' usine de
flins transformer son activité de
production en un centre dédié à
l'économie circulaire
toutes les activités sont concernées par
la réduction des effectifs près de 4600
postes sont concernés en france par des
mesures de reconversion ou de départs
volontaires
les avis sont partagés du côté des
syndicats c'est un plan d'économies qui
a que pour ambition de réduire les
capacités de renault à répondre aux
demandes des populations
mais cette activité autour de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'économie circulaire
ne fera pas une activité suffisante pour
le personnel c'est un minimum 1000
suppressions d'emplois sur le site de
flins pato est maintenant on va entendre
une pale de négociation ou assez
travaillé avec la direction pour à
comprendre les tenants et aboutissants
et surtout plus pratique le plus
important c'est clair qu'on se dirige et
à quoi peut ressembler renault en 2003
avec un cac pèse que ce soit dans les
collectifs faut bien qu'on ait cette
vision là autre conséquence de ce plan
d'économies le programme e tc art de
rénovation du technocentre de guyancourt
pourrait être revu et re est étudié pour
réduire les coûts